from the studio with a 20% average on
Rotten Tomatoes comes the movie that
proves a fun premise a good director and
Peter Dinklage are still no match for
Adam Sandler somebody's more important
pixels you've been waiting for a funny
Adam Sandler movie since uh let me see
Big Daddy has its moments maybe the
wedding singer was definitely something
before a little Nicky gotta help her I
gotta help dad huh yikes now get ready
for a feature-length version of a pretty
cool YouTube video which sparked a
bidding war that Adam Sandler won and so
America lost watch what happens when
Sandler gets his hands on a cool premise
about humans versus video games with
three unfunny man children dusting off
their old game skills because our
soldiers are too dumb to recognize
simple patterns please and Kevin James
is the fat stupid president
slog through Sandler's last release
before he forced himself on your Netflix
homepage as he does the same act he's
been doing since Billy Madison we're his
only jokes are comparing someone to a
pop culture reference Gandalf and Harry
Potter Thank You General Zod Zac Efron
dude you're just saying names of people
what are we doing right now with too old
it's just gross already but the Sandman
is never alone you know he's gonna bring
his old crew along for the ride like hey
wait that's not Rob Schneider Peter
Dinklage what are they doing here not
cool man suck all you want but don't
drag Tyrion down with you watch Sandler
finally break new ground were instead of
telling the story of a schlub getting
out of his league he gives you three
different love stories about schlubs
getting out of their leagues like
Sandler creeping on his married boss you
do smell good Dinklage gripping on
Serena Williams and Martha Stewart who
have a three-way and Martha subpoena
sandwich and Josh GAD turning Qbert into
a hot chick he can bang but they still
have Qbert babies what the [ __ ] who
cares anymore clearly they don't so
enjoy this film made for people old
enough to love retro video games but
young enough to find humor like this
funny if she was real a book written and
illustrated by Ludlow lamonsoff you
should sell it at Barnes & unstable ie
nobody in a movie that surrounds Adam
Sandler with all the ingredients he
needs to make a decent flick but gets
bogged down by a signature blend of
product placement
you lazy joke's second favorite
president you know Obama's still my man
right and you know him
starring they're not gonna laugh at you
pearl burp Merle kirb a lannister must
have needed to pay his debts no laugh
George are blings and jibs souls I know
it looks like Sean Bean didn't die in
this movie but look closer at his eyes
see he's dead inside be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers hey
screen junkies do you love movie fights
and video games then get ready to push
start on our brand-new show gamer fights
where we gather the internet's best
gamers to debate the topics you care
out click the box to watch our debut
episode featuring Matt Pat Greg Miller
and lasercorn while you're there you can
also check out honest game trailers
commentaries where the minds behind
honest game trailers tell you the
secrets behind each awesome episode and
don't forget you can get new episodes of
all these shows each and every week only
on screen junkies plies check it out
where the hood where the hood where the
hood at your words will disappear your
house will disappear your name will
disappear all memory of you will
disappear is this the Krusty Krab
I choose trial by dancing I can do that
ensign authorization code nine five
Victor Victor two